I the person that I have to think the
hardest is the love of my life Chris
whom when I first met her she was
looking for a job she said but later I
think she decided she was really looking
to get her hands on my camera which I
thought was reasonable and I right away
could see that she could be the partner
that I really always was looking for the
person who had the same was driven by
the same passion for a certain kind of
film that I was and that's 36 years ago
and we haven't changed although when we
make a film yeah give her hand I so
beautiful she spent two hours getting
made up tonight and she looks fantastic
but when when anyway she she she and I
have made a lot of films together we
made of course the the war room with
Nick Dube who I think is here and and
and and when and when we make films when
you shooting him your great friends
because there's nothing but problems to
be solved so your pals and then you sit
down at either the steam back or
whatever editing machine er is and it
all begins you get divorced about four
times a week and but you know it's a
process even though you're practically
choking each other to death over its
each editing decision there's nothing in
the world i love better than doing that
with her it's just my favorite thing so
even if i had nothing else to do that
would be the thing i would choose that
would be the best fun so anyway that's
she knows all about this because I tell
her all the time I we the the two people
that well are the one person that
that was very instrumental in my
education as a filmmaker was was Bobby
new earth and he he sort of knew how to
function in a or in a group of people
without disturbing them and yet watching
what they really did not what they
pretended to do and that was that was
that that was something I was I needed
to learn because I had never really
filmed with the number how most of the I
films were like daybreak Express I just
got Duke Ellington music and you can't
you know what can you do worse than that
and then I I think later that we we
worked with Joan Churchill and Alan
Barker and we did a film searching for
Jimi Hendrix and it was so marvelous to
have somebody that I knew on the other
coast we didn't have that we had no
budget for it so we couldn't come flying
out here to do something and Joan what
and and Alan what they did was just as
good as anything we could have done so
it taught me that people were learning
and getting its good at this as they
needed to and that was a very exciting
possibility and then one day RJ Cutler
and Wendy edinger came to visit us and
neither him whatever made a film am I
going too long do you think you want to
overwhelm this thing here but nope all
right well anyway
they had never made a film and they said
why aren't you making a film about the
selection and we said what election you
know Anna teeth so they really knew well
I'm getting mixed signals from my family
here and and and and so they said well
we'll get you we said we don't have any
money and we don't know anybody there
and at this point I think Clinton was in
fourth place in New York so and even
though my enthusiasm was for Clinton I
didn't see how to make that into a film
and they said well we'll get you a
little money which they did and we'll
find out will call up and get you some
people to let you in and and they did
that and we made the war room with them
and that was sort of a marvelous thing
you're saying all right all right so
anyway I want to say I'm really grateful
for this this amazing award and it what
it tells me or what I get from it is
that as a as a kind of a foreigner from
New York who cool all my life you know
everything I learned about films was in
watching the movies that the people out
here made I mean that's that's my
education in film and that watching
those films and thinking about this
award has made me feel that finally that
the the between here and in New York
there's finally some kind of a bridge
and that you guys all somehow now
consider us fellow filmmakers and that's
wonderful thank you